yo give me your rundown on how not to
get bipped into Bay
how do we knock it we go visit the bay
how do I not get bit
um first off don't stop by no gas
stations by the airport okay
um never do that
um don't be getting out your car and
putting [__] in the trunk
don't do that don't leave anything and
when I say anything don't leave nothing
at all in your car like don't leave a
charger don't leave [__]
um me personally I crack my windows
um
so you'll you'll you'll let you'll be
like windows are down yeah why not take
a peek if you want yeah I'll crack my
windows um yeah but for the most part
just don't have [__] in your cars and
then you know I I know how to look for
bippers when I'm pulling up and [__]
like I can spot the bippers and I damn
never know [__] like they see me
getting out the car and [__] like [__]
respect enough not to bit my car also
like don't rent a car rentals you're
gonna get your rental you're gonna get
your ass bit like no matter what yeah
cause people be stupid not no matter
what but people just be stupid like
why is you leaving backpacks in a car
like I just think people don't know I
just had so my dad is like going to San
Francisco with my sister and my mom
and I had to give him the rundown I said
whatever you do
and I said if you're going to Denny's
take everything with you into Denny's
and then not overnight too because I
know people that follow you and then
stop out that red light while you're at
that red light though while you're at
the red light they'll bip you bro and
get what yeah I'm saying but there's
that viral video there was like a split
in the freeway yeah that was serious as
[__] yeah all the time and they took
everything out and then hit the hit the
I said damn yeah but that happens more
that was just caught on camera that [__]
happens daily like you know like you'll
be in the car and
yeah but you're supposed to be paying
attention anyway looking at your mirrors
and [__] like why do you think that
that's like a prevalent thing in the
band I know like it happens in L.A but
it's like a thing in San Francisco it's
just like flocking is a thing in L.A
it's a hustle bro right like people was
rich off the PIP and nobody is above the
bit all right [__] a pip your mama
like [__] a bit they mama like it's
almost like treasure hunting the baby
you [__] around and get the right car
you might that's what I'm saying this is
Rich off the bed bro like yeah but just
my advice just don't leave nothing in
your car
um
pay attention like you really can't
um it's gonna happen like eventually you
really can't not
um you like get away from the bip like
ain't no telling who's bipping like I
would just like I think I was just
telling my boy uh oh shout out to Brian
Sampson but we're talking about going
out there and I was like yeah if we get
a car it's gonna have to leave the trunk
open leave all the windows down not even
that just do your [__] in your room bro
no for sure but I'm like just to not
deal with the broken window oh yeah it's
more about dealing with the broken
window
yeah and then um two the [__] car uh
the window shops repair shops oh they're
just uh they're just racking it they're
running oh that'd be a great business
move to the Bay open up a window shop
open it up by the airport oh you're
eating bro yeah they're racking it in
bro for sure oh are they so I the last
time I went to the city there was all
the CVS's were closed because of that I
think it's uh you could steal up to like
yeah they're still eight dollars yeah
it's wild San Francisco is a different
place is it like that in Oakland no okay
no what I just closed one of the
Walgreens in um 34th because they
they've been tearing that up for years
but Oakland is not as bad as the
different mayor different police force
yeah different exactly and then um
like San Francisco like they just forgot
about their homeless like that [__] is
sad yeah that [__] is sad like that [__]
is like damn near um what a whole Bay
like California period is turning into
tent cities for sure L.A it's been like
I mean Ellie's [__] up but the thing
about La is like it's not concentrated
anymore so I feel like you go to San
Francisco you'll see a lot of homeless
people but I feel like if you drive to
like I don't know Daly City or something
you're not going to see as much as much
right right if you're in L.A no matter
where you're at in L.A you go to Sherman
Oaks you go to [__] Venice wherever
you're at there's tents bro right right
and it's sad because we're California
like and then uh not even to get into
hell of politics like this but help me
understand this bro like
where do we get this money from to find
and help other countries when they're in
dire need but we can't do it for our
country bro I don't disagree with you
man
yeah like it's like wait hold on but
Flint's water's still dirty right like
what
it's crazy it's all geopolitical
[__] it's let me ask you a question
yeah uh could you come on my podcast
yeah all right don't just say that
because we on your [__] Bro imma hold
you too and you've been chatting on me
too bro yes you have bro yeah bro this
[__] let me tell y'all so one time I
don't know I hit you up look bro what's
your name
Cyrus one time we in LA right so I gotta
pull up the history no no no so one time
we're in L.A he oh yeah blood man I'm at
the reschedule
I got sick I'm like okay cool right I go
to the Freddie Gibb [__] right
who I see in the corner I'm shaking
their ass I wasn't shaking my ass right
hey by the way if I go walk up that was
the day after no it wasn't it was the
day no it was the day was it the same
day same exact day so my boy Tash like
bro isn't that Kev right there I'm
looking you know I'm rolling the dice
I'm like oh it is I go walk over there
I'm like bro what's up he oh you little
blood yeah man I feel a little better
like yeah okay by the way by the way by
the way okay by the way I definitely was
not feeling good uh secondly Freddy's
thing I wouldn't have missed
I'm one of my best friends in the world
I'm not gonna miss this [__] but I
definitely was not I was I was
definitely not feeling I had to cancel
two interviews that day okay you weren't
the only thing I canceled all right
next I was talking to Cyrus and then the
other the other thing is anytime I'd hit
you you'd be like you just tell me the
day you see I don't I don't like to
operate on that because I got to think
too much man I'll be like if you tell me
hey I'm gonna be out here the 14th
through the 17th how you doing Eric
where's Eric Eric just went outside with
this barking dog he just got decided to
bring the [__] work today
he just got this dog and decided to
bring it in like he's not gonna Park and
he's telling everyone don't worry it's
not gonna bite you like you just got the
dog how do you know she's a sweetheart
she's a sweetheart bro she won't bite
you but the dog's barking at me I'm
trying
I'm trying to see here oh wait I'm
looking no we already you said you were
gonna miss it we're here yeah bro yeah
no I definitely I'm down yeah I wanna uh
I definitely gotta come through man yeah
that'd be dope as [__] and I appreciate
um you know I appreciate the look like I
said